[Musique]
voici la plus grande usine de
biométhanisation du québec à
saint-hyacinthe
ici on transforme des résidus
agroalimentaires comme des fruits des
légumes et tuyaux gour en énergie le
procédé a lieu dans ces immenses
cylindres qu'on appelle bio digesteur la
matière biodégrader produit du gaz
naturel puisque iaa retire c'est du ch 4
c'est-à-dire le méthane le méthane qui
attaquent la la d'ordinaire la couche
d'ozone mekhissi est complètement capter
le gaz est ensuite injecté dans le
réseau d'énergie re le plus important
distributeur de gaz au québec on
l'appelle alors du gaz naturel
renouvelable du gnr la ville en produits
de façon continue depuis avril 2019
saint-hyacinthe est la seule vélo québec
qui injecte du gaz qui est transformé à
partir de matières organiques dans le
réseau d'énergie
le gnr et plus écologique que le gaz
naturel standard qui est du gaz de
schiste fossiles dont la production
pollue au québec 14 % de l'énergie
consommée provient du gaz naturel mais
un centième seulement et du gaz
renouvelables le gouvernement qui vient
d'annoncer 213 millions de dollars pour
financer des projets de gnr demande à
énergie redents distribué cinq fois plus
qu'en 2025 ce 5% d'ici 2025 pour moi il
est tout à fait atteignable
aujourd'hui on a une quinzaine de
projets qui sont soit en service ou qui
sont en développement qui devraient
entrer en service au courant des
prochains mois un de ces projets
s'annoncent comme un modèle à suivre
et il sera en opération au printemps à
warwick une douzaine d'agriculteurs en
sont les propriétaires et il y enverront
leur lisier
normalement ce qui arrive aux avec les
leviers sont là on la voit pas ici en
mai dans la fosse dans la fosse est la
deuxième source la plus importante pour
l'ensemble la filière laitière
la deuxième source d'émissions de ges
la production de gnr ici sera suffisante
pour chauffer mille résidences
annuellement énergie repéra pour cette
contribution et les agriculteurs
pourront rembourser leur investissement
en 10 ans ils pourront aussi utiliser le
compost produit par l'opération comme
engrais pour leurs terres il ya des
études qui ont été faits que le
potentiel agricole c'est le plus grand
potentiel actuellement qu'on a pour
développer le gnr au québec
en introduisant davantage de gaz naturel
renouvelable ça va nous permettre
d'avoir une économie qui va être
décarboniser sans compter à 100% sur
l'électricité qui va être très
importante mais qui à elle seule ne
pourra pas satisfaire tous les besoins
énergétiques d'un moindre coût
je pense qu'on est à un tournant décisif
andré bélisle milite depuis 16 ans pour
que le québec prenne le virage vers la
biométhanisation des petits projets
comme celui de ben louise dit il le
québec pourrait en accueillir une
centaine
c'est surtout dans ce domaine là qu'il
est t elle dans le domaine de des
petites communautés où les gens se
serait agi ensemble pour éliminer le de
la fouille smac l'avenir passe aussi par
la collecte des résidus domestiques le
fameux bacs bruns
aujourd'hui les villes qui offrent le
service envoie sur tout son contenu dans
des sites pour en faire du compost
en 2019 montréal envoyer sans 4000
tonnes de matières organiques au
compostage les villes qui continue quant
à elle d'envoyer leurs matières
organiques à l'enfouissement n'auront
plus le droit de le faire à partir de
2025 on pourra pas marie toutes les
bleues de patin
si ça pète donc il faut faire quelque
chose et ses sauts que la bio méthane la
biométhanisation nous propose deux
immenses projets verront le jour en 2022
celui de la ville de québec qui aura son
usine de biométhanisation dans le
quartier limoilou
puis la première des deux usines
promises par montréal depuis dix ans
celle de montréal-est dont la
construction débutera sous peu ici sur
le terrain de l'ancienne carrière des
mix près de l'autoroute métropolitaine
rabot prendre l'énergie à partir d'une
assiette de table des gaz avec et on va
l'utiliser a entre autres pour agea
marcotte le pont menaçante d'épuration
des eaux usées le traitement des eaux
usées c'est ça qui va chauffer
l'immeuble cette usine aura la capacité
de traiter 60 mille tonnes de matière
par année même chose pour la deuxième
prévue dans l'arrondissement lasalle en
2026 on a pris énormément de retard dans
toutes ses usines de biométhanisation de
traitement des matières organiques
municipal il ya un manque de
coordination de planification il va
falloir mettre les bouchées doubles pour
faire progresser ces projets là mais
c'est réaliste la matière première est
là encore faudra-t-il que les citoyens
participent suffisamment en 2019 le tour
de récupération des matières organiques
dans l'agglomération a été de seulement
28 %
on n'a pas atteint nos objectifs au
niveau de huit logements et moins au
niveau de l'adhésion de toujours l'effet
waouh du début après s'il ya un petit
recul est maintenant confronté des
campagnes de sensibilisation
mais on le voit sa sexe elle a de plus
en plus il y un autre enjeu et non le
moindre
au prix du marché actuel un client
résidentiel qui paie mille dollars pour
sa facture au gaz naturel conventionnel
devra plutôt payer 1200 $ si le
chauffage
électricité et 1600 $ s'il chauffent au
gaz naturel renouvelable
récemment le gouvernement canadien
annonce et le son souhait de voir le
carbone taxi a plus lourdement dans un
avenir relativement rapproché
donc cette école dont vous parlez moi
s'amuse avec elle dans l'arrondissement
saint laurent à montréal
l'oréal canada accepte de payer 35 %
plus cher pour chauffer au gnr les
équipements à vapeur de son usine de
produits capillaires le gaz consommé
vient des mêmes tuyaux mais payer plus
lui donne une image de marque tout en
faisant sa part pour l'environnement
et ça fait près de trois ans qu'on est
bonne à ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'on
ne consomme 100 % de l'énergie
renouvelable on vraiment que selon les
sondages que les clients soient
remportées à voir des échoppes plus éco
responsable avec le bain
la demande pour le gaz naturel
renouvelable est bien présente dit
énergie re
l'entreprise soutient avoir aujourd'hui
près de 800 clients d'affaires qui
serait prêt à en acheter